gave here Gabriel Martinez and his wife
and his brother you guys where are you
guys there you are right back there a
game is celebrating his 37th birthday
he says 37 being a rather apropos for a
Kevin Smith related function 37 yeah
he says keeping with the show's motto
all Anil all the time I didn't know that
was our motto by the way I hadn't told
you but it seems you work in the clubs
Phil you know the man great folks know
about that that's why they're here man
great book some commercial time on that
Anil program I've heard so much about I
was hoping to hear a little conversation
between Peter Lorre and Charlton Heston
imagine it's 1960 he said please give me
characters a time a place he's giving
you more to work with than I have ever
done well done
all right convincing my wife to give up
the o-ring so Peter Lorre at Charlton
Heston in 1960 are having a conversation
about her [ __ ] all right all right
here we go
Charlton counting are you going to vote
for Kennedy or for Nixon I haven't
decided yet Peter
I get the sense that Kennedy may be a
gun control nut he certainly will be in
a few years in Dallas but how would I
know that because it's only 1960
more importantly we have to tell
Gabriel's wife to give up the [ __ ] oh
my god get your goddamn paws off her
sphincter you 38th and see
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]